you've learned a lot about confidence
everything ranging from the architecture
of a continent to how to use it for
image recognition to object detection to
face recognition and neuro style
transfer and even though most of our
discussion has focus on images on sort
of 2d data because images are so
pervasive it turns out that many of the
ideas you've learned about also apply
not just to 2d images but also to 1d
data as well as to 3d data let's take a
look in the first week of this course
you learn about the 2d convolution where
you might input a 14 by 14 image and
convolve that with a five by five filter
and you saw how 14 by 14 convolved with
five by five this gives you a 10 by 10
output and if you had multiple channels
maybe there was 14 by 14 by 3 then it
would be 5 by 5 that matches the same
three and then if you have multiple
filters say 16 filters you end up with
10 by 10 by 16 it turns out that the
sooner idea can be applied to 1d data as
well for example on the left is an EKG
signal also called an electrocardiogram
it's basically if you place an electrode
over your chest this measures the little
voltages that vary across your chest as
your heart beats because the little
electric waves generated by your hearts
beating can be measured with a pair of
electrodes and so this is an EKG of
someone's heart beating and so each of
these Peaks
corresponds to one heartbeat so if you
want to use EKG signals to make medical
diagnosis for example then you would
have 1d data because what EKG data as is
this video time series showing the
voltage at each instant in time so
rather than a 14 by 14 dimensional input
maybe you just have a 14 dimensional
input and in that case you might want to
converse with a 1
filter surrounded in the 5.5 you just
have a five-dimensional filter so with
2d data when the convolution allows you
to do was to take the same five by five
feature detector and apply it and lots
of different positions throughout the
image and that's how you wound up with
your ten by ten output what a 1d filter
allows you to do is take your five
dimensional filter and similarly apply
that at lots of different positions
throughout this 1d signal and so if you
apply this convolution what you find is
that a 14 dimensional thing convolve
with this five dimensional thing this
will give you a 10 dimensional output
and again if you have multiple channels
you might have a 14 by in this case and
you gauge is just one channel if you
have one lead or one electro / EKG so
times pi by one and if you have 16
filters maybe you end up with 10 by 16
over there and this could be one layer
of your confident and then for the next
day of your confident if you input a 10
by 16 dimensional input and you might
convolve that with a 5 dimensional
filter again then this needs to have 16
channels so that has to match and if you
have 32 filters then the output of the
another layer would be 6 5 32 if you
have 32 filters right and the analogy to
the 2d data is this is similar to how if
you have 10 by 10 by 16 data and you
convolve it with a 5 by 5 by 16 and that
has to match that will give you a 6 by 6
dimensional output and if you have 32
filters that's where the 32 comes from
so all of these ideas apply also to 1d
data where you can have the same feature
detector such as this applied to a
variety of positions for example to
detect the different heartbeats in an
EKG signal but to use the same set of
features to detect the heartbeats even
at different positions
all these time series and so confidence
can be used even on 1d data for a long
upon T data applications you actually
use a recurrent neural network we should
learn about in the next course but some
people also can try using confidence in
these problems and the next course on
sequence models which will talk about
recurrent neural networks and LCM and
other models like that will talk about
the pros and cons of using 1d confidence
versus some of those other models
they're explicitly designed for sequence
data so that's the generation from 2d to
1d how about VD data well what is three
dimensional data it is that instead of
having a 1d list of numbers or to the
matrix of numbers you now have a 3d
block a three dimensional input volume
of numbers so here's the example of that
which is if you take a CT scan this is a
type of x-ray scan that gives a
three-dimensional model of your body but
whether CT scan does is it takes
different slices through your body so as
you scan through a CT scan which I'm
doing here you can look at different
slices of the human torso to see how
they look and so this data is
fundamentally three-dimensional and one
way to think of this data is if your
data now has some height some width and
then also some depth where this is where
the different slices through this volume
are the different slices through the
torso so if you want to apply a
confident to detect features in this
three-dimensional cat scan or CT scan
then you can generalize the ideas from
the first line to three-dimensional
convolutions as well so if you have a 3d
volume and for the sake of simplicity
let's say is 14 by 14 by 14
and so this is the height width and
depth of the input CT scan and again
just like images don't all have to be
square 3d volume doesn't have to be a
perfect cube as well so the height and
width image can be different and in the
same way the height and width and the
death of a CT scan can be different but
I'm just using 14 by 14 by 14 here to
simplify the discussion and if you
convolve this with a now a 5 by 5 by 5
filter so your filters now are also
3-dimensional then this would give you a
10 by 10 by 10 volume and technically
you could also have by 1 if this is the
number of channels so this is just a 3d
volume but your data can also have
different numbers of channels then this
would be x 1 as well because the number
of channels here and the number of
channels here has to match then and if
you have 16 filters there that 5 by 5 by
5 by 1 then the next outputs will be 10
by 10 by 10 by 16 and then if so this
could be one layer of your confidence
over 3d data and if the next layer of
the confident convolved this again with
a 5 by 5 by 5 by 16 dimensional filter
so this number of channels has to match
that as usual and if you have 32 filters
then similar to what you saw with
confident over images now you end up
with a 6 5 6 by 6 volume across 32
channels so 3d data can also be learned
on sort of directly using a three
dimensional confident and what these
filters do is really detect features
across your 3d data cat-scans medical
scans is one example of 3d volumes but
another example of data you could treat
as a 3d volume would be movie data where
the different slices could be different
slices in time through a movie and you
could use this to detect motion or
people taking actions in
so that's it on generalization of
confidence from 2d data so also 1d as
well as 3d data image data is so
pervasive that the vast majority of
confidence are on 2d data on image data
but I hope that these other models would
be helpful to you as well so this is it
this is the last video of this week and
the last video of this course on
confidence you've learned a lot about
confidence and I hope you find many of
these ideas useful for your future work
so congratulations on finishing these
videos I hope you enjoyed this week's
perm exercise and then look forward
also to see you in the next course on
secrets models